celebrities always pop up in super bowl
ads
after all the night is one of the
biggest commercial opportunities of the
year
and this year's festivities were no
different everyone from john travolta to
carl weathers popped up in a miracle
grow ad while paramount plus did the
unthinkable by bringing together sir
patrick stewart spongebob squarepants
james corden beavis and butthead and the
creepy girl from the ring
isn't it glorious but there was one
celeb whose super bowl spot had viewers
feeling not quite alright alright
alright
academy award-winning actor matthew
mcconaughey outdid himself once again in
a super creepy ad for doritos 3d
throughout the commercial a completely
flat paper version of mcconaughey is
shown struggling to do the normal
everyday things he'd do if he weren't
squished so thin
he has trouble driving his convertible
ordering a coffee appearing on talk
shows and going on walks
did you drive here or did you travel by
fax
thankfully there's a product that brings
fullness back to mcconaughey's life
doritos 3d
he effortlessly slips into a vending
machine filled with a snack
after eating a 3d dorito mcconaughey
becomes a three-dimensional human again
though he ends up trapped in the vending
machine for his trouble
there's no question that the ad is
clever but the unsettling uncanny valley
styling and the way that the totally
flat mcconaughey moves and acts is
causing a stir online
in fact everyone seems to have an
opinion about matthew mcconaughey's
dorito 3d ad
over on twitter super bowl viewers and
doritos eaters alike wasted no time
expressing their feelings about the
commercial
sharing that they were unsettled and
creeped out by the look of
two-dimensional matthew mcconaughey it
seems most people understood the
creativity and humor that went into the
creation of doritos 3d super bowl ad but
that didn't stop some from fearing
they'd experience nightmares after
watching the flattened out version of
the actor wiggle around inside a vending
machine
ashley reese joked on twitter matthew
mchibby
looking all flat deeply upset me
meanwhile frozen actor josh
gad suggested a lucrative idea 3d dorito
matthew mcconaughey needs to do a
crossover with lincoln matthew
mcconaughey that of course references
the numerous ads mcconaughey has done
for ford's luxury automobile division
lincoln for what it's worth
mcconaughey's appearances in those
commercials have reportedly driven up
sales over the years so celebrity
endorsement really does work
take a long way
after the doritos commercial aired
lincoln even took a moment to get in on
the joke tweeting a photo of doritos
crumbs in a lincoln with the caption
doritos guess we should have seen this
coming huh comedian jared breed was much
more blunt about how mcconaughey's
dorito commercial made him feel
writing on twitter paper matthew
mcconaughey will haunt my dreams for the
rest of time
elsewhere comedian frank caliendo
hilariously wondered how much weight did
matthew mcconaughey lose for that
commercial
others in the twitter sphere said things
like the matthew mcconaughey flat
stanley doritos commercial was the thing
of nightmares and my life is worse for
having witnessed it and that matthew
mcconaughey doritos advert is going to
haunt my nightmares
um okay what's that mean means i'm bad
at parties
on the flip side some thought the
commercial wasn't creepy at all and only
found the humor in it one twitter user
took some time out of their day to write
so far the matthew mcconaughey doritos
commercial is in the lead for best ad
another viewer argued the 3d doritos
commercial with matthew mcconaughey was
the best one of the night
hashtag flat matthew award-winning
reporter laura geller admitted that she
found the ad pretty funny but also
confessed she might be biased because
she has quote a minor crush on matthew
mcconaughey hey
who doesn't
yeah however it was bachelor producer
elon gale who arguably summed the whole
situation up the best
he simply tweeted flatbug mcconaughey as
for mcconaughey himself he hasn't
weighed in but clearly he must have
gotten some joy out of it since he was
willing to appear in the segment in the
first place you'll have to decide for
yourself whether mcconaughey's
commercial is funny or just plain freaky
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite super bowl highlights are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one